[Music]
glow is about 1985 women's wrestling
television show women who are very
different such a thing they have in
common is that they're kind of at a
breaking point in their lives
where if something doesn't change
something insane is going to happen the
80s women were still looking for elastic
Rika of stereotypes and be treated as
equals what I'm interested in are real
parts not secretaries telling powerful
men their wives are online too and to
play roles like this was kind of daring
I love that sound it's a group of brave
beautiful misfits coming together and
finding a place where they belong over
the next two days I'll be casting a
squad of 12 women play wrestlers on
television this whole job has been
totally female forward our creators our
women our producers our women
14 members of the castle women it was
very smart and unique casting and
there's a very diverse and interesting
group of women like a parade oh my
goodness thank you so much all of them
have very quirky talent
[ __ ] actresses we wanted everyone to
do their own wrestling which is a big
commitment I was really intimidated
about the rently I'm scared to ride a
bike but after we started doing things
we didn't want to stop I was like I'm
picking you up
and they really cared and supported each
other he's on the saga those that
couldn't do something from frustrated
she have five six girls support me right
there come on you can you know you can
do it yeah and no universe of these
fourteen people be best friends
and yes because of this intense thing
they're going through it really brings
them together you become really close
very quickly when you're in each other's
like armpits there's a lot of crutch to
face every woman has a wrestling
character sleeping inside of him and I
think that people are going to look at
it and be like that's exactly how I felt
in traffic this morning
there's comedies there's drama there's
active we would all be in our trailers
reading the script and you can just hear
like gasps or laugh or crying there's
something in it for everybody to watch
[Music]
you
you